i wanted to have a very brief research
review about sedentary time um just
because i've been digging into some of
this literature and this kind of builds
upon uh some of your previous segments
about walking you know because
uh
a lot of times we think about sedentary
time and we think about okay uh it seems
to have an independent deleterious
impact on health and wellness how might
we rectify that and
one kind of proxy measurement you can
use is daily step count which which
you've kind of addressed generally
speaking if you have a pretty high step
count it's unlikely that you have
a tremendous amount of total cumulative
sedentary time because you're out there
walking a lot it also it at least play
places an upward constraint on how much
scent exactly you can have yeah it's a
proxy yeah it's not a perfect indicator
but generally speaking if you have a
high step count that is likely to at
least correlate with having
relatively lower total sedentary time
and theoretically relatively fewer
very prolonged stretches of continuous
sedentary time generally speaking if you
have a pretty high step count it means
you're getting up you're moving you're
walking and generally speaking having
less total sedentary time and hopefully
less continuous sedentary time as well
um so just to kind of build upon that i
wanted to talk a little bit more about
the independent ramifications of
sedentary time and a couple other
strategies that you could use outside of
just monitoring step count because i
know for some people
monitoring step count you know there are
some people that really like to have a
very quantitative approach to their
health and wellness they like to track
everything they like everything to be
numerical uh and they can you know do
different types of interventions to
influence those numbers but i wanted to
talk about a couple other potential
strategies so first of all
it's important to establish that you
know you established very effectively in
previous episodes that low step count uh
seems to be associated with some
deleterious outcomes related to health
there are other meta-analyses that have
looked not just at step count as a proxy
but specifically looking at different
forms of sedentary activity and how
those relate to health and wellness so
for example
there is a meta-analysis by patterson
and colleagues and i'm going to link all
three of these in the show notes
but patterson and colleagues found that
total sitting time and television
viewing time were associated with higher
risks of several different chronic
disease outcomes and that was despite
controlling for physical activity so
we're talking about the independent
impact of sedentary time that you can't
necessarily offset by saying hey i you
know i go for a jog three days a week
like there is uh it's difficult to
defend the case
that regular participation and
structured exercise completely nullifies
the deleterious independent impact of
being sedentary for large portions of
the day
especially for extended discrete periods
of time so patterson and colleagues
found this despite controlling for
physical activity uh biswas and
colleagues found significant
associations between sedentary uh
sedentary time and risk of a variety of
negative health outcomes related to
mortality and chronic disease incidents
um
and this negative impact from excessive
sedentary time it was certainly more
pronounced among people who had low
physical activity levels but
the association still persisted after
controlling for physical activity in the
entire sample
and then finally eklund and colleagues
found that sedentary time was
significantly associated with mortality
risk in individuals with low activity
levels low physical activity levels
and it was interesting because they did
some stratification by physical activity
level and you know like i said the the
the
association with negative health
outcomes uh
was or mortality risk i should say was
significant in the lowest uh third of
physical activity levels but if you look
at the high activity moderate activity
low activity kind of subgroups within
each of them you could see the same
pattern where regardless of where you
fall like having high activity level
certainly attenuated you know especially
like for this is relevant to people who
do structured exercise it seems to
attenuate the magnitude of the
deleterious outcome from sedentary time
but the general relations relationship
still persists what i and what i mean by
that is when you look at the low medium
or high activity groups within those
groups you can see that relationship
where the higher your sedentary time
gets uh the more likely that you're
gonna see an elevated risk of all-cause
mortality uh so
this is uh collectively the literature
indicates that you know certainly it's
good to do structured exercise and to
have you know a really intentional focus
on
getting out and doing discrete bouts of
physical activity uh but there's still
an independent negative impact of really
excessive sedentary time and we see
these kinds of things in uh studies with
athletes right even competitive athletes
you can look at some some research where
within a cohort of competitive highly
you know you know really well trained
athletes there are still associations
between sedentary time and outcomes
related to body composition for instance
i know
uh dr helms the other eric
reviewed a paper in mass a year or two
ago looking at the fact that uh among
really well-trained athletes higher
sedentary time was associated with lower
relative fat free mass and higher
relative fat mass so this stuff persists
even among people who have
a really high level of engagement and
structured exercise